when you win a war any previous
territory or losses are often swiftly
returned to you yet whilst Prussia had
been on the winning side of the
Napoleonic Wars when France had been
defeated and occupied prussia's previous
loss of this territory in 1807 was never
rectified and in fact it was handed over
to Russia which raises the question why
why did Prussia lose this land even
after it was Victorious so to begin
during Napoleon's Adventures across
Europe numerous coalitions formed to
oppose him one of these coalitions was
the fourth Coalition which was comprised
of these nations trying to prevent
France from creating a new European
order the Coalition didn't fare too well
and shortly after Napoleon had occupied
Berlin the Prussian sued for peace in
the peace treaty it was dictated that
Prussia would lose all of these lands
with this large chunk here becoming the
duchy of Warsaw the First Independent
Polish state since Prussia Russia and
Austria carved up Poland Lithuania at
the end of the previous Century seven
years later Napoleon Was Defeated then
again A year later in France was
occupied and in no position to dictate
its own borders let alone those of
Prussia so why was it ended after the
dust had settled a chunk of Russia's
polish territories were a part of the
Russian Empire and had not been returned
whilst Prussia did lose a lot of its
polish territory it did keep most of
what it had gained in the first two
partitions however there were two main
reasons that this land was lost to
Prussia forever the first reason was the
most obvious Sweden you see after
prussia's losses in 1807 its place in
the Coalition was diminished and thus it
didn't command the same level of respect
that it once had both Prussia in Sweden
had eyes and territory in the
german-speaking parts of Europe and if
Prussia spent too much political
Goodwill trying to regain Poland then
that would leave Sweden with a greater
foothold in the area the second reason
was that Russia was occupying the lands
when pushing Napoleon back to Paris the
Russians had conquered the duchy of
Warsaw and had placed it under military
Administration Prussia wasn't exactly
excited at the prospect of fighting
another major war that it would likely
lose and so there really wasn't much
that they could do that's not to say
that the Russians weren't going to
compensate Prussia for the loss Emperor
Alexander the first knew that Prussia
had a claim to the land and so in return
for handing water in the Polish
heartlands over to Russia it would
support prussia's expansion Westward
which worked well for both sides for
Prussia it meant that it would lose a
great chunk of its Catholic
polish-speaking population and could
replace them with the Richer
german-speaking Protestant populations
to its West it would also increase
prussia's influence in the new German
Confederation at the expense of Austria
which was a fun bonus for them and for
Russia gaining Poland was important
because Alexander believed that some of
Napoleon's liberal ideals were here to
stay and so it was better to paint
himself as Poland's Liberator and
protect her than to risk Prussia getting
it wrong and Poland Breaking Free this
wouldn't last for long because after
Poland revolted in 1831 its status as an
independent state was abolished and it
was formally incorporated into the
Russian Empire as a territory and with
that Prussia lost control of Poland and
its successor State Germany would only
briefly regain it during the first World
War I hope you enjoyed this episode and
a special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle
kosher wolf Jerry lambden Jordan Longley
Adam Stalter Marcus Arsenal YN hockey
Spencer Lightfoot rod Martin words about
books podcast Captain side dog Gustav
Swan Marvin Castle commune Winston K
wood boogly Wiggly Daniel to be in Miss
is it Aaron the white Corey Turner the
macquapa Alex Schwinn Anthony Beckett
Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she went in
spinning three plates and Charles the
first